[Music]
foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream we are live on
Rumble where the speech is free and the
drinks are complementary meaning that if
you listen very closely to them they say
nice things about you that's all we can
promise spelled differently
is it
that shocks me I did not see that coming
although just one little bell in the
middle one little yeah complimentary
complimentary really I know it's
terrible wow okay really irritating
being a speller I gotta tell you wow
it's not as irritating never mind no I
know um
um yes so I'm Dr Brett Weinstein I mean
let me say that's that's the way with
buttons I mean they don't work if
they're not spelled differently at some
level well actually I believe that there
are really two categories there's a
category in which they have to be
spelled differently in a category in
which divorce
haven't yet encountered those as far as
I can tell but um maybe there's
something I don't know
so anyway I was going to say that I am
Dr Brett Weinstein you are Dr Heather
hiing
um and here on the Dark Horse podcast we
sometimes address the question
what is a woman but we always address
the question who is a woman because you
are a woman in addition to being a a
biologist I'm I'm one of them yep yep
one of the half of humans on earth a
little bit more than half at this point
it's interesting right a tiny bit more
than half of how humans because of the
hold my beer phenomenon which reduces
the number of men yes yes
um actually not not a little bit more
than half a few months on Earth are
women a little bit more than half of
humans on Earth are female women being
adult human females uh so but we're not
actually going to go there today despite
the cover of Glamor magazine did you see
the cover of Glamor magazine in honor of
queer month third pride month I'm sorry
whatever it's called yeah Megan Kelly uh
altering her position on the entire
question as a result of it which I found
interesting uh I have no I have not
she's awesome I have not seen what she
has to say but yeah no this is um
the activists are radicalizing a number
of of us who were very very interested
in being respectful of people who were
respectful and asked to be acknowledged
as
um that which they were presenting as
but this has gone a lot too far but I
don't think we're actually going to
really go there uh today there's a it's
a long month oh boy is it going to be a
long one so I'm sure we'll come back too
I guess it's called pride month not not
I said queer month that's not right but
it's going to be a queer month but it is
pride month yeah I don't know why it's a
whole month that seems amazing to me I
do not recall the meeting in which we
decided that that was the right way to
do it well that probably wouldn't have
happened at the meeting of the
patriarchy no thanks you know definitely
not no that's the only meeting you
attend don't think we were eluded it is
I mean it's the only meeting worth
attending at some level but
um you know it's it's pretty casual
nothing so far has been true
in the whole history of humanity almost
nothing that at least I've said
uh today on on air okay so we are on
Rumble as you said you did say that that
is true Glenn Rumble join us here
subscribe to our Rumble Channel
seriously uh we are our Clips are going
live on Rumble our live streams are live
on Rumble as you would expect and our q
and A's are only on Rumble we will then
upload the most to Spotify but not on
YouTube uh not on anywhere else and I I
just want to say
um you want to help us out signing up
for our Rumble channel does that it's
free you gotta sign up for rumble then
subscribe to our Channel
um and anyway it's not zero cost because
it'll take you a few minutes but it's
worth it and it does help us and we do
notice and um thank you for doing it
indeed
okay
um oh so the chat is live on Rumble and
only on Rumble uh our our moderator or
moderators
um often are are there
um getting rid of obnoxious and stupid
comments so
um so let's let's let's have a high
level chat we don't see it but we hear
from people who do and uh we're looking
for it to be a place where people can go
and have conversations simultaneous with
with us having our conversations and
we've seen garbage chats go go good
before so
um to the extent that people are still
getting their footing that's fine but uh
bring it up a notch see how it goes
indeed so we will be doing a q a this
week only on Rumble as I've already said
um and with regard to other places that
you can find stuff that we're doing I of
course write on Natural Selections at my
sub stack
this week I wrote about uh generation c
song between what seemed like
overexposure uh to to many of us and to
many of them as well posting absolutely
everything online and now it being the
young who are at least in the places
where I am frequenting who are most
likely to be in masks in public and it
feels like
potentially a way to sort of claw back
some privacy that has been disappeared
from their lives and it's it's there's a
sadness that I feel there but that's
that was the subject of what I wrote
about this week on sub stack
um I would add one more thing
um your sub stack is excellent very
popular and people really love it
um
I have not yet put anything of
consequence there but I'm going to uh
you can now subscribe to my Twitter feed
if you want some special content and
that is on the way for those of you who
have already done it thank you
yes uh
and we can
um you can get some some stuff from
darkhorsestore.org if you're looking for
uh
what what is the direwolf uh saying uh
saddle up the direwolves we ride tonight
right tonight we've got this fabulous
artist who who draws uh uh who makes who
renders ideas that we have into
beautiful 2D art and those are
represented in um in the gear uh that we
have at the store that is run by these
this wonderful couple in the middle of
the United States they print it there
and they ship it to you and it's all
really good so take a look at
darkhorsestore.org if you're looking for
you know Dark Horse merch or Pfizer
where the breakthroughs never stop the
uh epic Tabby which I was meant to bring
in the bag that I've got of the Epic
Tabby but anyway lots of good stuff
there
um
and they unlike the previous outfit that
we had our store on which did you know
which had a bigger bigger platform and
so they were able to you know push sales
at people more often but they censored
us as YouTube as censored us as other
people have censored us whereas where
we've now got our store that's not going
to happen so uh support us support them
go to darkhorsestore.org
we are supported by you so in addition
to subscribing to the rumble Channel
which as Brett said requires that you
sign up for rumble that's free uh and
then subscribe to the channel also free
not totally free in terms of your time
but you don't have to put out any money
to do so
um
and the rumble channel will have both
the full live streams and the guest
episodes and the clips and uh you can
also find uh most of the content still
on YouTube as well we have two channels
Brett's original Channel and our Dark
Horse podcast Clips Channel and we have
our patreons where just this morning you
had one of your monthly conversations
which was uh I imagine
it was fantastic it was fantastic they
always go places that I do not expect
but they are always uh rewarding and
enlightening and I think that's clear
because a bunch of people in there
who've been there uh forever and
um and love it apparently wonderful
wonderful and we do a private q a once a
month through my patreon we're going to
be moving um some stuff into locals soon
you can you can join us on locals but we
don't have anything up there yet uh and
uh through either of our patreons you
can find our Discord server where
there's a tremendously good uh community
of people who uh who meet and talk
sometimes they meet in real life and
they do all sorts of stuff together uh
including they send us a question which
we start off our q and A's every every
time we have a q a with a question from
our Discord server and of course we have
sponsors uh we do three ads at the top
of every live stream and some of the
guest episodes have ads too and we as we
have said repeatedly are very very
choosy about who we allow to advertise
on Dark Horse we reject many of the
sponsors who approach us not necessarily
because the products aren't good but
because they just aren't a fit for us so
if we are reading an ad it's because we
really and truly actually vouch for
these products so without further do
these three
our first sponsor this week is a new one
to us fast growing trees
plants are life and a thriving Garden is
healing in so many ways fast-growing
trees can help you get Lush healthy
trees growing on your land quickly
they've got everything from fruit trees
to shade trees to trees that provide
privacy and their fast reliable shipping
gets whole healthy trees to you fast we
had a crab apple tree delivered to us
this week from fast growing trees and I
am super impressed it arrived fast was
packaged beautifully like so well I I
you know I decided when they first
approached us I was like really you're
going to ship trees through the mail
that's going to be tough but the Box
arrived in perfect shape it was packaged
super well once I got inside it was
clear you know how it was secured so as
not to move around but without any
excessive packaging great instructions
on how to open it on the box it was very
straightforward it was clear to the
person who delivered it what they were
supposed to do clear to the person who
opened it was
nice job awesome
the box and I didn't notice those
directions
uh okay okay so I I reopened it and then
extracted the plant which was zip tied
in place re-unboxing do they yes no they
don't you do you should buy rights I see
so this tree uh which was opened twice
and then on actually unzip tied from its
from its secure position in the Box just
the once uh uh is in is in fantastic
shape for the moment I've just put it
into a pot because I'm going to move it
around a couple places the landscape to
see exactly where I want it but it's
clearly a healthy plant with tons of
potential and we are sold on fast
growing trees it's really um it's really
a great uh great company
fastgrowingtree.com's Plant experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between
whether it's your first home or a
seasoned Garden fastgrowingtrees.com has
experts in the field ready to support
you and your plants for years to come
fastgrowingtrees.com has your perfect
plants shrubs and trees with fast
growing trees fast and efficient
shipping you don't have to wait in line
or haul plants home in your vehicle you
order online your plants arrive at your
door in just a few days and that was
definitely as I said our experience with
the crab apple tree that arrived earlier
this week
and with fast growing trees 30 day alive
and Thrive guarantee you know everything
will look great fresh out of the box
join over one and a half million fast
growing trees customers who are very
happy with with
their customers
with their trees I skipped some words
early in the sentence and I just
couldn't recover it no seriously there
are a million and a half happy fast
growing trees customers join them now go
to fastgrowingtrees.com Darkhorse now to
get 15 off your entire order that's 15
off your entire order at fast growing
trees all those words are spelled the
way that they're supposed to be spelled
there's no other ways to spell them
fastgrowingtrees.com Darkhorse
all right it was a struggle but we got
there our second sponsor of this week is
seed a probiotic that really works your
gut and your immune system work together
coordinating your body's response to the
world both around and within you seed
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means it supports you
becoming healthier overall our resident
gut microbes directly impact the
development and function of the immune
system even before born microbes
microbes
microbes inform our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is the substances that our
body doesn't recognize as its own
you can support your gut immune access
in a variety of ways one of them is by
prioritizing sleep for instance your
body operates in a 24-hour cycle that's
your circadian cycle and new research
suggests that the gut micro microbiome
has its own circadian clock and that
changes to your normal rhythms can
disrupt your microbes and the important
functions that they perform this is one
of many reasons that prioritizing
regular and sufficient sleep can help
keep your gut immune axis healthy you
can of course also support your gut
immune access by taking the seeds ds01
daily synbiotic that's syn biotic seed
is a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strains have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards Digestive
Health as you would expect from a
probiotic and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin for instance your skin like your
gut has its own microbiome seed supports
both gut and skin health and other
systems of Health as well
seed is free from 14 major classes of
allergens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically double hauled with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon where you want it and the
same design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary you could
travel with it you can have it in your
medicine cabinet you don't have to worry
about keeping it cold like you do with
most probiotics
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours I use it I love it so
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to our team routine I can't
recover that to redeem 25 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily synbiotic
that's seed.com s-e-eed.com Darkhorse
and use code Darkhorse
clinically or scientifically tested love
that distinction that's the point we
should do a deep dive yep indeed all
right our final sponsor it will not
surprise you to discover is mind Bloom
mind Bloom is the leader in at home
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of scientifically robust medicine with
clinically guided support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being if you or someone you
love is struggling with mental health
issues those issues May Loom large in
your life there is no one-size-fits-all
solution but you know that you and your
loved one need something that will help
achieve a real and Lasting breakthrough
maybe it's time for you to consider a
guided ketamine Therapy Program from
mind Bloom mind Bloom could be your next
and most successful chapter in improving
your mental health and well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience to begin take mind
Bloom's online assessment and schedule a
video consult with a licensed clinician
to determine if mind Bloom is right for
you if approved you'll discuss your
health history and goals for mental
health treatment with your clinician to
tailor your mind Bloom regimen mind
Bloom will send you a kit in the mail
complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only four
sessions 89 percent of Mind Bloom
clients reported improvements and their
symptoms of depression and anxiety
reports one client on their site quote
mind Bloom has enabled me to release the
hold of negative thought patterns in my
life end quote mind Bloom has guided so
many people into a better chapter of
mental health and well-being right now
mind Bloom is offering our listeners a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use promo
code Darkhorse at checkout
go to mindbloom.com
darkhorsepromo code Darkhorse for a
hundred dollars off your first
succession program today that's m i n d
b l o o m.com slash Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse at checkout
awesome
[Music]
okay we have a number of
things all sort of of a piece to talk
about today all relating uh broadly to
health and medicine and
and our role as individuals and the role
of Public Health agencies uh in
keeping ourselves and entire populations
healthy that's going to be our our large
Focus today with a bunch of different
inroads yep roads in
we are going to make inroads on some
roads in yeah it's how it's done that's
how the pros do it Dad I'm not sure that
my English is going to uh doesn't happen
continue to the end of the episode any
Earth language will do is my sense yeah
I think English is definitely I know
that English is definitely where I'm
best so I'll try to stick to English
that's your inroad then use it okay so
good Lord
we're going to start today
um by talking about
uh this commentary and you can show my
screen if you like Zach this is
published in the bmj which is a medical
journal uh originally stood for the
British medical journal although the
official name of the journal is now the
bmj uh the editor-in-chief I believe is
Peter Doshi and we've talked before
about some of um the excellent work he's
been doing at the bmj this is this is
one of the few if not the only medical
journal that I think reliably uh is uh
taking those people and organizations to
tasks that need to be taken to tasks and
so uh this last month it now being early
in June and May 15th of of 2023 there's
a commentary published by a David B Ross
associate clinical professor of medicine
called the decline of science at the FDA
has become unmanageable
I'm going to read a couple of sections
and then he is actually responding to a
piece that Doshi wrote that we will then
talk about as well doshik and the
editorian chief I believe of the bmj
so
um
in the section of this piece called
scientific culture Ross writes
what accounts for this for this dissent
into cargo called science
much of the blame must go to the fda's
Reliance on industry-paid user fees over
the past three decades the proportion of
the fda's annual drug budget made up of
such fees has risen from less than 10
percent in fiscal year 1994 to more than
two-thirds fiscal year 2023.
in addition the alluring regulatory
flexibility is provided by the FDA
modernization Act of 1997 and the 21st
century cures act have become habit
forming enabling the fda's leadership
and managers to deny scientific Reality
by defining Effectiveness downward
in its quest to avoid difficult choices
and hard decisions the FDA has
increasingly embraced non-inferiority
trials or vice versa we'll talk in a
moment about what that means ignoring
the serious regulatory clinical and
ethical problems caused by their misuse
however the corruption of the fda's
scientific culture Remains the primary
culprit driving the deterioration of
safety and Effectiveness standards that
is Ross walks through a number of the
perverse Financial incentives that the
FDA is wrestling with since a radical
change since 1994 and says all of that
is true but it's actually the lack of
the corruption of the scientific culture
at the FDA that is largely to blame for
the FDA basically and again the title of
this piece is the decline of science
that the FDA has become unmanageable
uh he writes the corruption of the fda's
scientific culture Remains the primary
culprit driving the deterioration of
safety and Effectiveness standards
during my tenure at FDA managers would
admiringly speak of crafting and
approval
as if it were a skillful demonstration
of regulatory Ledger domain rather than
an act of scientific fabrication
so that is that's a lot of claims that I
did I'm going to link to this piece of
course in the show notes but I haven't
yet
explained how he how he gets there like
on what basis is he making these
arguments and one of the Prime examples
that he uses is one that Doshi wrote
about in the bmj on the same day as that
piece was published did you want to say
something before I get there or well
there's there's a lot I want to say why
don't you get where you're going and
then we'll uh put it all together all
right okay so um again my screen if you
will this is uh that last the last piece
which uh these two pieces are linked
they're published on the same day in the
same Journal that was a commentary this
is called a bmj investigation
this one written by Peter Doshi senior
editor at bmj called did the FDA break
its own rules in approving the
antibiotic recarbio
FDA scientists said that they couldn't
draw any inferences from the clinical
trials for a new combination antibiotic
from Merck but the agency approved
ricarbio but the agency approved
ricardio anyway
okay so Merck is one of the big big
pharmaceutical companies of course now
we're still we're going to do this for a
little while here Zach
um Mark is one of the big pharmaceutical
companies
um along with along with Pfizer and and
a number of others and they apparently
have a a generic antibiotic which does a
lot of good and which is uh a 40th as
expensive as this newly proposed drug so
just a few sections from this uh this
investigation by Doshi and the bmj a
couple of weeks ago
despite the absence of any clinical
studies to provide substantial evidence
of its Effectiveness the agency approved
the drug a product 40 times more
expensive than an existing generic
alternative so this new antibiotic is
um basically three three drugs in one
the generic that it is being
being suggested to replace in some cases
being a drug that is out of patent and
still effective uh but we're we are
supposed to believe this one is perhaps
better well how do we know that
instead of testing the hypothesis though
she wrote vocabio's possible superiority
over imepenem that's the generic that it
may or may not replace in patients
lacking treatment options Merck's trials
test today non-inferiority hypothesis in
patients who already had effective
options
not inferiority is an awkward term
indicating that the cuti trial that is
chronic sorry that is complicated
urinary tract infections
non-inferiority is an awkward term
indicating that the complicated UTI
trial tested whether adding relentbactum
to impenim did not worsen the efficacy
of independum by worse than 15 percent
so let's let's just say that again
because I was stumbling over some of
those words which I'm not totally
familiar with they've got imapenem again
I may be mispronouncing it as the
generic that Mark already makes but is
out of patent and so is now quite cheap
they are pushing this new this new drug
uh recarbrio through the FDA on on what
basis well it's it's not even totally
clear because they're not doing
superiority trials they're not even
apparently claiming that this is better
than what is already out there what the
trial the testing that is being done is
this non-inferiority trial in which they
are assessing whether or not this new
drug which is independent plus some
other stuff is worse than what's already
out there
a classic rationale Doshi continues for
doing a non-inferiority study is to test
experimental interventions that may
offer non-efficacy benefits such as
improved safety or greater convenience
as a trade-off for some loss and
efficacy remember this is a drug that is
40 times more expensive than the
existing drug
there is no proposal that it has
approved safety or greater convenience
in fact it couldn't possibly have
greater safety because it has the
original drug plus two more right
non-inferiority trials Doshi continues
are therefore not designed to address
the question of improved efficacy over
existing drugs but rather to test that
any loss in efficacy doesn't exceed a
level deemed clinically acceptable
the fda's review memorandum noted that
the agency generally accepts 10 percent
worse efficacy for non-inferiority
studies in complicated urinary tract
infections however Merc chose a 15 worse
efficacy cut off why did they get to
decide
allowing as many as one in seven
patients to potentially have a worse
outcome and still declare the trial of
success
but the trial results didn't even meet
Merck's 15 worst Target for the
complicated UTI indication efficacy
results showed that riccarbio quote
could be as much as 21.3 percent worse
than the control group the FDA wrote
so this goes on and on and on
you would think maybe that given that
the wrong test was done
with a lower standard than the FDA
prefers and they failed even at that
lower standard that the FDA might say
you know what no guys not not this time
but that's not actually where we go okay
so that's the last thing I I um you can
you can give me my screen back that's
the last thing I actually highlighted in
here but no they um they went ahead and
approved it despite there being
um
no tests for superiority and they failed
the test rate inferiority and
um so wait no no they set an insane
standard
for a New Drug combination yes failed to
meet it and approved it anyway on the
basis of nothing
why would you want
a new drug that combines an existing
drug that is now quite cheap because
it's out of patent
that is that existing drug plus a couple
other other things well maybe it's more
effective maybe it works
four conditions like complicated urinary
tract infections for which sometimes the
original drug I've forgotten what it is
in my prime or whatever it is isn't
always effective that's what you would
want to know does this work in those
cases for complicated UTIs for instance
that the original now generic drug
doesn't work
well we don't know because they didn't
look what they looked at was they took
patients who didn't have complicated
UTIs who did not have situations that
could not be treated with the existing
cheap generic they took patients who
could very effectively be treated with
the existing generic they then did not
see if this new combination is better
than the existing drug no they did a
non-inferiority study and not only that
but they didn't use the standard that
the FDA has set they used a lower
standard yet and they didn't meet that
standard and yet the FDA said you go
girl like go for it we're going to go
ahead and approve this drug
there's so much here I know somewhere in
the history of Dark Horse episodes
there's an extensive discussion of what
I called uh the game of Pharma or the
Pharma game right the idea was something
along the lines of you get intellectual
property rights over a molecule you find
some condition that it plausibly treats
you run studies that make it look
effective you
game the studies enough that it triggers
the threshold where you have to give it
to everybody so there's no control group
and you can't but find the adverse
effect whatever right right this is a
whole new level
it seems to form a game right because
first of all you've got a drug that
works that the Pharma company doesn't
like anymore because they can't make
much profit it's out of pro it's out of
patent how can you get it back in well
there's lots of games you can play right
you can slightly modify it and it may
ruin its uh efficacy a little bit but
the point is maybe it retains enough
efficacy in its new form and you can
plausibly claim that it has some
Advantage yada yada there's lots of ways
to do it it does keep profits up here's
another way to do it
you take the drug that doesn't work or
that does work it does work and it does
work but it's out of patent you take it
and you put it in a novel combination
now that's fattenable right the point is
the things you put it with
don't have to work because you got a
drug in there that works you couldn't
patent it it was out of patent so you
couldn't profit from it now you can
profit from it again right and the
problem is now you got to get through
the FDA a whole other time what are you
going to do well there's a test at the
FDA uh has called non-inferiority that
seems weird why would they have such a
dumb test oh there's a very good reason
for that test and it has to do with the
fact that you know maybe you're allergic
to a particular drug and so you want
some other drug and you would accept the
fact that it doesn't work as well as
long as it's not too much worse or I can
imagine a situation where uh like the
original drug is very effective but it
needs to be refrigerated right and so we
want we want a different drug for the
same problem uh that can reach rural
areas where areas without Refrigeration
areas have been ravaged by a hurricane
right so you you want something there
are there are reasons to do
non-inferiority studies right sure right
there are reasons to do non-inferiority
studies for example the two mentioned
right you've got uh it could be that
you're getting a cheaper drug so you'll
be able to treat more people maybe the
drug is so fantastically expensive it
can't be used but something a little bit
inferior that's a lot cheaper that'd be
cool or something that's safer something
that has a different mechanism of action
safer is good yeah I would accept less
efficacy if I was safer in taking it oh
those are both great rationales I like
to hear you're taking a test that is
appropriate to that situation where you
might be able to achieve cheaper safer
or both with not too much inferiority
and you are using it in order to produce
a drug that is more expensive and
inherently more dangerous not just not
safer inherently more dangerous and how
did we know that well a it's got the
original drug in it so if you were
allergic to that you'll be allergic to
this but also it's got two new drugs
it's got two new drugs and what don't we
have on these two new drugs is any
long-term data over what happens if you
take them I don't know I don't know
actually I don't remember if the two
other things are also compounds that
Merck has already you know put out into
the universe previously well at least
with the methodology described there is
no reason to think you couldn't do this
with a brand new molecule we knew
nothing about in order to get it into
circulation you would get some efficacy
because it's now been fused with
something that actually works but and
just like antibiotics antibiotics are
tricky are remarkable right like one of
the great successes of Western medicine
antibiotics when
um use when when used too frequently or
um in in too dense a population probably
will breed antibiotic resistance of
course and so the idea that you might
have and you know they give a couple of
examples here but the one that Doshi
writes about most is for the case of
complicated urinary tract infections
which are complicated perhaps in part
um do they are called complicated
because they are resistant to many
antibiotics it's possible that that
original now generic very cheap
antibiotic that has been effective
against many UTIs is not in the case of
this particular patient who's got a
complicated UTI and so we need more
kinds of drugs on the market and maybe
that original antibiotic plus a couple
other things which help nudge it in the
right direction might actually do the
trick
obviously you need a superiority test
they are not a non-inferiority test
obvious obviously all right and a couple
points one triple drug cocktail my guess
is this is actually responsive to the
irresponsible use of antibiotics that
has created resistance in the first
place so Pharma creating a niche for its
own novel compounds because the original
compounds it's like a kind of planned
obsolescence whether it's planned or not
um but
and then I guess the question is okay so
you've approved this new drug cocktail
that is
expensive inherently
more hazardous because it contains
things that are potentially novel or at
least a novel combination so we don't
know anything about what long term
happens to you if you do that something
that might be detected clinically right
um
so they do this and then what's going to
happen this is now approved my guess is
Merck stops making the generic right it
doesn't actually change the production
because they're still using the molecule
but now they've got a whole new
rationale for using it in an expensive
form so the point is this is this all
speaks to a single underlying truth
which is
Pharma
if it was ever interested in health has
long since abandoned that mission and
has become a mechanism for leaping
regulatory hurdles by altering the
landscape by co-opting the referees
whatever it's done
getting stuff to Market getting it
labeled as standard of care whatever
it's going to be done right in order to
make a profit at arbitrary Health
expense and arbitrary Financial expense
to the customer but
I guess the the surprising thing I I'm
surprised that I continue to be
surprisable
the surprising thing to me here is not
that that is what Mark is doing of
course that's what Mark is doing Merck
has a responsibility to its own bottom
line
they are not in the business of
pharmaceuticals because they
fundamentally care about human health
they are in the business of
pharmaceuticals because they are in
business right
what is surprising to me here is not
what Merck is doing
but that the FDA which is the regulatory
agency which is supposed to be
protecting us American citizens
is not just com complicit but actively
aiding and abetting uh the the work of a
business
to uh to impoverish and presumably make
less healthy the citizenship the
citizenry of the United States right so
um well I just want to say on the one
hand this is completely shocking from
the point of view of citizens who are
depending on an FDA we don't understand
to protect us in the case of
pharmaceuticals that we all encounter at
some rate right so you absolutely expect
that this thing has your backs that's
what it was set up for
the problem is this is a classic case of
adaptive Evolution and a niche right and
to the extent that Pharma actually
influences the political environment it
also shapes the niche which then shapes
the FDA which then regulates or fails to
regulate or facilitates in this case
what the pharmaceutical company is doing
which goes to what I'm going to call the
fee Paradox fee from
that too okay I don't know if that's
spelled differently I don't care
actually you know you think it's fine
either way
um but the the idea right you as a I
don't know a citizen of the realm who
recognizes that Pharma is you know being
facilitated by the very existence of
civilization and the Very existence of
the expensive medical architecture that
we have built and that they maybe ought
to pay their fair share of the
regulation of their industry right and
so you set up a structure where they
have to pay for the work of figuring out
if their drugs are safe it's only fair
right and the point is actually
I don't want those people anywhere near
the process of figuring out if their
drugs are safe I I want them to submit
drug and walk away because they're not
allowed in the room they're not allowed
to tell anyone anything about whether or
not this thing is safe and then I want
people who are paid to remain
independent to test the safety of this
thing to debate what the rational
standard would have to be to debate what
the standard of care ought to be right
that those two things there needs to be
what in business would be called a
Chinese wall or something that separates
the production and profiting from these
molecules from the testing of whether
they are safe and the decision about
whether or not they should be given to a
position an X Y or Z situation right
it's I mean it's maybe the least
interesting part of this story but uh
because they failed even the standard
that Merck said but the FDA sets a
standard of 10 for non-inferiority
studies and Mark used 15
what is Merck used like why why does
Mark get a say why is Merc doing the
work at all but
how did we get here like
what what is actually going on this is
this is remarkable we got here
I mean as always if you set up a system
that has the basic characteristics for
adaptive Evolution to happen it will
happen and what we've got is a system in
which because we did not specifically
engineer it to avoid evolving in this
way of course it will and you know
that's what happened and the problem is
that if you're like most people
you are at best aware that there is some
undue influence of these companies right
and you think oh that's really
unfortunate but you think it's a
perturbation on the system rather than
you think it's a parasitism when it's
actually a parasitoid it has destroyed
the system that is looking out for your
health and it's actually actively
putting you in danger and in this case
we know that it's putting you in danger
not only are you now going to have a
drug combination on the market that is
inherently less safe because we don't
know what its long-term implications are
but by making it more expensive you're
pricing a certain number of people who
need drugs out of the market and so the
the point is this is not about
delivering Better Health to people this
is about delivering more profitable care
irrespective of its effect on your
health
that's right
so um
in considering this reporting that Doshi
did I thought well
let's just go see how the FDA presents
itself
so I went to their web page and you may
show my screen here Zach until I tell
you to take it off show it for a while
here and this is the front this is just
fda.gov
U.S Food and Drug Administration helped
stop the spread of a misinformation
you can help get the facts from the FDA
stop the spread of false rumors and
share the facts with your loved ones
when I click on that I'm just I've got a
screenshot here how to report
misinformation online
this is the FDA FDA we face this is the
top thing on the on the very front of
their website how to report
misinformation online remember this is
the same FDA that just proved a drug for
which they have no evidence that it is
actually better than the existing drug
we Face the challenge of an
overabundance of information
related to our Public Health over
abundance of information some of this
information may be false and potentially
harmful
editorial comment yep a lot of that's
coming from you guys
inaccurate information spreads widely
and its speed making it more difficult
for the public to identify verified
facts and advice from trusted sources
such as the FDA
however everyone can help to stop the
spread yes they did
everyone can help to stop the spread
yes not a viruses anymore it's
misinformation that we're stopping the
spread out now if you see content online
that you believe to be false or
misleading there's a typo but okay to be
false or misleading you can report to
the applicable platform and they have
helpful links to Facebook Tick Tock
Instagram LinkedIn Twitter WhatsApp and
YouTube
fantastic fantastic thank you FDA now
you know what's not on that list
Rumble yeah yeah
indeed okay so stay on my screen here
for a moment
that's
remarkable yeah that is remarkable that
is the top thing on the fda's site
that's what happens when you click this
little read more button okay okay let's
go down let's see what else the FDA has
in store for us
sun protection options for all ages get
our expert tips on how to stay safe in
the Sun for every stage of life from
sunglasses to sunscreen find the way
that works best for you now I'm not
going to read through this whole thing
but I will tell you this
the FDA which just approved a drug on
the basis of no evidence that it is
better than an existing drug but the new
drug is 40 times Marx's more expensive
than existing drug
is promoting two things primarily on its
side at the moment
calling in misinformation when you see
it and trusting only verified facts that
you get from places like the FDA and all
of the dangers of being in the sun
here's the way that you can protect
yourself from the sun the sun the sun
the sun it's super dangerous there was
literally nothing in this article I
searched mentioning Ben
sun vitamin D near infrared radiation
anything about the fact that actually we
need sun exposure to be healthy nope the
FDA much like the who last we talked
about the who last week and they're
getting up on their high horse about
salt it's salt that's the anime not
the experimental treatments that you
forced almost everyone on the planet to
take nope it's salt well the FDA is
pushing a new hyper-expensive antibiotic
on you which we don't actually know if
it's safe or effective and warning you
because it is an agency that cares about
your health to make sure to stay out of
the sun no matter what that is our
Public Health apparatus as it stands in
2023.
obscene it is obscene and I okay am I
seeing a mirage or what
you've got an agency that's supposed to
be on our side that has been captured by
the thing it's supposed to be regulating
and is clearly working for them
advocating a monolithic approach to sun
exposure that will make people unhealthy
across the board because of the wide
number of processes in which vitamin D
appears to be an important player
creating ill health which then will
result in the prescription of drugs that
these people make did I imagine that no
no he did not imagine it it's um if you
had said that to me 20 years ago
I would have said come on man
stop in 20 minutes that's not gonna
happen man
20 minutes ago yep 20 minutes ago it it
it it didn't begin to make sense but it
did begin to feel like reality so and
that's an important distinction
okay again things that seem like they
would have to be mirages right okay the
CDC didn't
botched the job when it came to covid
they got it upside down you did exceeded
the opposite of what they told you to do
you'd be way better off right you should
be at the skate park you should be at
the beach you should treat the disease
early you should take vitamin D the
opposite of their advice was the right
thing to do yep
this idea that the FDA is recommending
that you avoid the Sun
and mind you I'm not telling you to get
a sunburn right sunburns are bad there
are ways to avoid sunburn sunscreen may
be involved but you want to be very
careful because a it actually is a
complex chemical compound that enters
your system more than likely depending
upon which version you have if you're
spraying it on you're going to be
inhaling it all sorts of hazards that go
along with it right it should be dealt
with very carefully and it should be
dealt with sparingly because you want to
have as we talked about at length during
during the pandemic what that whatever
that even means right vitamin D is
essential it is best produced on the
skin we are almost all who live at high
latitudes deficient especially during
the winter they are giving that they are
committing malpractice on their site not
telling you at the very least sun
exposure is a trade-off
tumors are a hazard
you need to avoid tumors that are
induced by sun exposure short of tumors
you need to get sun exposure so you
produce enough vitamin D to be healthy
and fend off disease it's simple it
needed to be said and it's not said and
that is
um you know they're not they're not
doctors so I guess it isn't malpractice
it's uh you know criminal negligence or
something but
um well I guess I wonder
um
I wonder about beginning to use the word
treason
it's a public health agency paid for by
our tax dollars
uh and I did not find a mission
statement I'm probably there's one on
their site I got I was so shocked at the
misinformation and Sun stories that were
the top of their site that I stopped
there but it seems to me that their
mission has to be related to
um protecting the health and well-being
of the American public who paid their
bills
and they're doing the opposite we've got
you know three stories today right uh
doshi's reporting on their their pushing
through of this drug for which they
don't have the evidence and that's
that's putting it nicely
um who have pushed it through and then
they have the FDA
saying that you really need to get your
facts from from them and maybe a few
other sources and Report misinformation
that you find online and then arguing
that uh any and all sun exposure is bad
like literally not a mention not not
even a throwaway phrase in this piece
about uh the benefits of you know they
they could have done it they could have
said benefits of limited sun exposure
you know before 10 or after two you know
you know and you know I don't I don't
buy that either but they could have done
it in a way that at least wasn't
egregiously
anti-scientific and known to
it's just about everyone at this point
to be bad Health advice protect yourself
from all of the Sun at all times
no just just no so who like what is
their job what do they understand their
job to be and if they and if their job
is as I think it must be as an agency
funded by American taxpayers to to work
for us and they are actively providing
uh information that is bad for us
maybe it's too strong word but it feels
treasonous
well I I'll push back a little bit on
that not because I don't think in the
aggregate it is because it obviously is
um the question is how does it happen
right treason is something that
individuals are guilty of right it does
it requires intent or no yeah okay it
does
um
the problem is there's an awful lot of
uh the banality of evil where people who
are doing something narrowly end up as
part of an evil structure right they end
up
Staffing something and you know at the
point that you're Manning a gas chamber
you're guilty right at the point that
you're filing paperwork for the
equipment that is involved in creating
gas Chambers it's a different question
right you should know but do you it's
possible that you don't right and
cognitive dissonance is powerful right
and part of the game that's been played
on these agencies is
they are I in my opinion deliberately
underfunded right so there's they're
stressed so as to fund the IRS right but
they're deliberately underfunded so that
they have to cut Corners so that they
are grateful for the fees that they get
from the companies that they are then
supposedly regulating right they can't
attract the best talent because the jobs
don't pay well and so the point is the
whole thing is built to produce this
outcome but yes
all true
I don't even know what the best talent
means at this point you know the the
schools are so bad there are a lot of
people who have the appropriate
credentials who would look at that piece
on the sun and say well yeah of course
you have to stay out of the sun oh yeah
we're we are probably killing people
again by suggesting that you need to be
out in the sun like that's going to be
the insane criticism that that comes our
way because we are saying
look this one doesn't even require that
much Nuance but there are trade-offs and
nuances required and if you're going to
pick a single metric
a single answer it's go out in the sun
but actually a single answer isn't the
right one it's moderate and mitigate and
pay attention to how you feel and don't
burn but yes get exposure to the sun on
your skin and generate vitamin D because
that is the best way to do it better
than eating it in your food and it's
hard to get in your food and that way
you are likely to improve your health
far more than
most medicines you could take
I agree with that perspective I also
think that once again we are in a
position to do a vastly better job right
what they've effectively done is they
have given you advice that at if we are
maximally generous focuses on one
parameter your likeliness of triggering
a melanoma from a sunburn right if that
was the only Health consideration then
the advice to effectively get yourself
out of the Sun and if you can't get
yourself out of the sun then uh you know
use sunscreen to block out as much of
the Sun as you can right we can also say
that much as
the insanity of the recommendations that
came
in the pandemic
was visible in the complete failure to
risk stratify anything right the point
is oh get your shot
really I'm seven and I'm healthy and I'm
a boy and I would get myocarditis more
likely from your shot than I would get
from anything else I could possibly do
right so we're not gonna you know exempt
the seven-year-old healthy child we're
not going to exempt the person who has
natural immunity from having already
been infected and gotten gotten over it
right and then in this case the sun
exposure thing did you find anywhere in
looking at their site on ways to avoid
the Sun
anything that mentioned the fact that
depending on your race that this is a
very different consideration because
there's another one of these just as
with covid your risk from covid went up
with age and your risk from the shots uh
went up with youth right we have a case
here where your risk of vitamin D
deficiency goes up with uh the darkness
of your skin
so you know telling people avoid the sun
use sunscreen you know does that make
sense to tell a black person whose
ancestors come from close to the equator
who's you know moved to Minnesota to
avoid the sun I think that's exactly
you're in danger of vitamin D deficiency
right and you're probably and
essentially no danger from skin cancer
right right so they say they have two
mentions in this piece one sentence
people of all skin colors are at risk
for this damage
okay okay uh the second one is slightly
better people of all skin colors are
potentially at risk for sunburn and
other harmful effects same article
right the first sentence I read said
everyone's at risk the second sentence
uh says people of all skin colors are
potentially at risk for sunburn other
harmful effects of UV radiation so
always protect yourself be especially
careful if you have pale skin or blonde
red or light brown hair so yeah it
doesn't first of all it doesn't get
anywhere near here there's never
anything there's nothing positive that I
that I saw in here and I didn't by
searching all the terms I could possibly
think to which whichever suggests there
is a moment when there might be a
benefit to you for being in the sun
without being protected yeah which is
yeah
which is Bonkers yep
so that's the FDA yeah yeah last week we
talked about the who
um and uh wasn't any better
it wasn't no better all of the agencies
have to be captured otherwise it's a
it's a zero as a special number question
because if there was an issue you know I
mean in some sense the British medical
journal is the weird exception right it
sure is it's a journal in which you've
got an editor who's Wide Awake who's
talking about you know the absurdity of
what's going on at the FDA that's a
threat to the FDA and uh Pharma for
which it chills and and um I don't know
I I I hope though she succeeds in uh in
his mission yeah
all right uh let's uh
can I say pivot or is that is that a
word that we don't use anymore
um
I it feels dated
you know every so often somebody will
declare that um there's a word that if
you use it uh you're obviously a hack
and sometimes it's a word that's I think
we even started using early you know the
valence that something has right that's
now been declared uh
um Beyond The Pale somehow these people
yeah exactly
um but I think I think we can pivot okay
well pivot is not a word that we started
using so I feel you know when it when it
comes out of like Silicon Valley culture
and it feels like oh yeah that kind of
makes sense yeah I'm I'm willing to
abandon it at the point that it feels
like it's overdone yeah but let's uh
let's move on
uh let's move on before circling back oh
God
uh you want to talk about uh a piece
that uh Rob Aurora uh published yeah
exactly you might want to explain a
little bit about who that is and what's
going on here so RAV is a very
interesting guy he is a young journalist
um who by his own accounting uh sort of
fell into journalism I think out of high
school and he has done an editing for
himself
that sounds dangerous no I think he's
he's gifted in this way he probably
rolled and yeah yeah learning to fall
yep yeah exactly um anyway so RAV has
been
increasingly on the uh covid beat and in
particular has been chasing down
evidence of
um
Adverse Events and patterns and and the
like and and was given his demographic I
think particularly interested in uh the
rates of myocarditis among young men who
received the MRNA vaccines yep
absolutely and he has of late teamed up
with uh Jay bhattacharya uh their
Endeavor is called False Consensus I
think I don't know um illusion of
consensus which this is something Jay
and I have uh bonded over the idea that
the Draconian measures that uh were
deployed by the official dumb
just created a huge penalty for stepping
out of line which meant that there were
a tiny number of people who actually
spoke their mind and dissented those
people were then driven to The Fringe
right J being a great example you know
professor of medicine at Stanford being
dismissed as a quack you know because he
opposed lockdowns
um but anyway the point is if you punish
people
strongly enough
for dissenting then you get very little
descent and then you can claim that
there's a consensus and then you can
punish people who question it because
who are they to question the consensus
so all doctors agree surely if we were
wrong there'd be people out there
disagree with us right so uh anyway uh
RAV and and Jay have teamed up on the
illusion of consensus and this piece
that RAV put out this week is a
continuation of a story that he's been
doing but this one focused on some of
his experiences as a journalist trying
to get his work into various
Publications and he reports that he's
been shut down by Publications that
basically flat out say oh well we're a
pro-vaccine publication we're not going
to publish your report that suggests
that there's something to worry about
because we're a pro-vaccine publication
what does that even mean you're a
journalistic publication you should
follow the evidence where it goes you
shouldn't have a perspective on these
things going into it
um but anyway the his current piece Zach
do you want to show it yeah now the idea
that there is a a publication that
purports to be a journalistic uh claims
a position in advance is utterly
remarkable it gives away the whole game
right away so here is uh his piece the
illusion of consensus is the place that
they've published it or rabbis published
it and the title is editor at quote
pro-vaccine publication end quote
experienced serious adverse event after
the second Pfizer shot
and what he does in this piece uh maybe
scroll down see if we can find the most
irrelevant paragraph
keep going
he describes uh keep going
all right I can't
uh anyway he describes the case of an
editor at a publication that was de
facto Pro vaccine
who after his second Pfizer shot found
himself this is a young very fit guy uh
who found himself shaking violently his
heart pounding in his chest so that he
felt it was going to ex explode
and he said he would have gone to the
emergency room this is a quote from the
anonymized source of the story but he
says that he would have gone to the
emergency room except that he uh he was
also delusional right now I wanted to
highlight the story
he's uh
I would have gone to the hospital but I
was honestly also delirious and wasn't
in my right mind it was extremely scary
woke up and my heart was still
noticeably racing but not super bad my
entire body was sore and I could barely
walk
that led him to the following rational
conclusion I decided that would be my
last coveted shot right now
okay so the story is pretty
shocking I must say not the only story
that we have heard of this type and
there there is a question which I will
get back to people experiencing Adverse
Events who have a public stance uh that
they feel
does not allow them to acknowledge that
they have experienced something negative
from the shot right now I want to unpack
a little bit the nature of the
environment I completely understand why
somebody especially a young person who
is not especially well established yet
right I know what happens to them if
they come out and they say
here is my story now in my opinion
if your story is true and it is relevant
to a question on people's minds I don't
care if you're the only person who had
an out an adverse event from this shot
right maybe you're the only person who
had it and by talking about your adverse
event you are going to cause alarm when
in fact statistically the thing is so
safe that that alarm is out of place
that is possible but to me
you as a member of the public
are entitled to
have some developing sense of how
dangerous something is based on how
often you hear these stories yes and if
you hear one in a journalistic outfit
you know that that's not like hearing
one from you know from your florist
right your florist is somebody you
interact with you have some idea how
many people you interact with you don't
necessarily know how many people were
census to get the one story Into the
journalistic publication so you have to
file it differently you can't you can't
calibrate you can't do sort of uh
and
impromptu probabilities on uh hearing
stories and journalistic outfits whereas
if you know what you know I talked to
you know 40 people a week that I kind of
know and one of them said this well it's
only one right but you do have a sense
of what that rate is in your own
personal
um experience right now you can look at
rav's story RAV talks about it's not
like he went looking for the one person
on Earth who had the story RAV was doing
a journalistic job trying to get stories
published you have some sense he's one
person you have some sense of how many
journalistic Publications there are he
reports on several of his interactions
with several of them and he says and
here's an interesting case right this
comes from his personal experiences
somebody he has met so it's not like
your florist but it's like somebody
tells you oh here's what my florist told
me right you still can't fully calibrate
because I don't think you know RAV says
you know I talked I approached
30 out outlets and yeah there are two
people at each and you know 50 of the
total people told me some stories like
we don't we don't know what is effective
is non-scientific but his effective
sample size right it's data I mean it's
not data but it is evidence right it is
evidence of something it cannot be
properly calibrated but I wanted to
point to something I keep mentioning I
keep wanting to mention this and I keep
forgetting to do it
there's a phenomenon this is going to
sound completely unrelated but you'll
see the relevance in a second
there's a phenomenon where back when I
was a biologist studying actual bats
if you catch a bat in a missed net
and the bat starts to shriek it is very
likely that the next thing to happen is
your net is going to fill with bats
it won't be all the same species okay
this is the result of something called
Predator inspection
right a screaming bat attracts other
bats not because they have a death wish
but because they want to know what the
threat is in the environment because
that piece of information is valuable
right if some animal has grabbed a bat
and is ripping it apart other bats that
see that animal know is the hazard in
the trees is the hazard on the ground
what sort of Hazard is it right and the
Predator is busy at the moment exactly
so it's not terribly risky to do
um but the point is the desire to have
information about hazards is very very
ancient
right and the ability to take in that
information and to alter your behavior
rationally is a fundamental feature of
navigating life now in the last thing
that we covered you see that the thing
that is supposed to be protecting you
the thing that is supposed to be
integrating all of the information about
the dangers and Hazards and all of that
is falling down on its job right it's
working for somebody else so you are now
your best defense what are you going to
do well you should look for evidence
that there might be something that you
need to know that the people who should
have alerted you are failing to do it
who should be alerting you well the FDA
should be alerting me ah this drug we
didn't approve it because X and
journalistic establishments should be
alerting you uh here are some stories
that we've collected that you ought to
know they're not doing it right so now
no they're not so here's the point
you have a right to protect yourself and
your family and your friends by
processing information you are being
denied information right these maddening
stories that happen where somebody has
suddenly died right they've died
suddenly and there is no mention of what
they have died of and the question is
obvious it's not that we want to believe
that they died of a particular thing but
if they did die of that particular thing
we are entitled to know that it happened
right yes we are yes we are entitled to
that information we are entitled to that
information so this brings us back to
this anonymized editor in ravaror's
story
I get
why someone would not want to go public
it has been made very clear and this is
a feature not a bug it has been made
very clear what happens to you if you
start telling stories about what
occurred after your vaccination right
you will be punished this is the most
despicable thing imaginable because in
each of these cases where somebody got
vaccinated and they have a story
these are people who did what they were
told
they listened and now they have a story
and that story might be misleading it
might be a one in a million story and
you know it's just dumb luck right or it
might be part of a pattern they have the
right to know if it's part of a pattern
and we have a right to know if it's part
of a pattern and the pattern Seekers are
not doing their goddamn jobs the CDC and
the FDA are not doing their jobs the
journalists are not doing their jobs the
journalistic establishments take a
position on the safety of the vaccines
before the author of the story even
walks through the door and those of us
who are scientists and Who as a matter
of our profession seek pattern and seek
to understand it and who are trying to
do exactly this job in part are told
you're not allowed to do that that's
dangerous leave the pattern seeking to
the authorities
there it is but the authorities are
refusing to do it
so if we're not allowed to do it and the
people who are supposed to be doing it
aren't doing it
how is it going to get done
how will we ever know the truth
how will the truth come out it won't
it won't and yet there are still people
yelling about how dangerous it is to
actually try to understand this on our
own
when literally none of the agencies and
none of the journalistic outfits that we
have been talking about have taken it on
themselves to be honest or forthright
about what is actually happening
they are busy confusing and burying
truth from the who to the CDC of the FDA
to the various mainstream media Outlets
that is what they are doing the opposite
of what they claim to be doing the
opposite of what they claim to be doing
and based on an assumption that the
tiniest amount of scrutiny reveals isn't
true right yes the idea that vaccines
are safe is wrong many vaccines have not
been safe right we have numerous
examples where a vaccine has been given
to people and then was pulled from the
market because it is dangerous so the
idea that what is causing you to have
this reflexive reaction to all stories
that go in the other direction is that
there's an assumption buried in your
model that these things have to be safe
because they're vaccines a they're not
they're not vaccines B if they were that
wouldn't make them safe right so the
point is look don't pretend that people
who got hurt when they went to get a
vaccination are anti-vaxxers I'm sorry
whatever that term might mean it doesn't
mean that right right I was injured by a
tiger doesn't make me tighter phobic
right the point is maybe now but right I
probably am but I got a story and it
will explain to you how I got there
right
um so anyway yeah I'm frustrated by the
transparent nature of the game yes right
yes you can threaten a person so that he
will
face the possibility of a cardiac
arrest that will kill him and then we'll
be silent about what caused it because
he also has to figure out how to feed
himself and his family for the rest of
his life right get it you've got
leverage but you don't have the right to
that leverage and
do people who find themselves in this
position
think you have a moral obligation to
figure out how to bring your story up
maybe RAV was the mechanism by which the
person called Ben in the story did this
and that that was the best he could do
because he needed to go on and continue
to earn a living at the same time it was
important that we have the story so if
that's what's going on right if Ben
delivered this story to Rav because he
was trying to thread that needle then
maybe that's the best you could do and
thanks for doing it it's far better than
there being no story but it would be
even better still if we had your example
and we could talk to you about what
happened to you and why you got the
vaccine in the first place how this
changed your mind and whether how rare
you think your situation is have you met
others because I have I've met lots of
them right so
well this is um this is actually a good
segue I think we're going to save
talking about skeletal editing for
another time which is not nearly as
exciting as it sounds it's actually
terrifying but we'll save that
um we're going to talk about this book
where there is no doctor a Village
Health Care handbook
by David Werner this one the one I'm
holding up here for those of you just uh
just listening says new revised Edition
but this is our book this is our copy
from 1994. it's a second publishing uh
from the second edition which was in
1992 originally published in 1977 in
English
um which was based on it was a
translation from the original in Spanish
donde doctor I did not know that it was
originally in Spanish but apparently
according to the frontus piece the the
front pages of of this book it was
originally in Spanish
uh so again this this copy of this book
is from 1992 and there is apparently a
new edition out last year 2022 I have no
idea
how it has changed I assume it has
changed somewhat uh it might be worth
getting but um you know one of very many
reasons to have actual hard copies of
books
the text in this these Pages have has
not changed Okay so
what is this book why who cares where
there is no doctor of Village Health her
handbook the back cover says this book
is for the Villager who lives far from
medical centers it explains in simple
words and drawings what he can do to
prevent recognize and treat many common
sicknesses this book is for the village
storekeeper or pharmacist who sells
medicines and healthcare supplies
explains which medicines are most useful
Etc this book is for the teacher in a
rural school it will help him give
practical advice and care to the second
injured Etc this book is for the Village
Health worker and this book is for
mothers and midwives who will find
useful the clear easy to understand
information for home birth care of the
mother and child health
um so this uh we in the 90s when we
bought this book in in 94 we were both
doing work in in remote places and I in
particular was spending a lot of time in
very remote places in Madagascar and I
had this book with me in a couple of my
longer field seasons
uh in Madagascar where I was living for
you know my my longest field season one
of the only ones that you weren't with
me on uh for five months on a little
island off the coast of Madagascar
living a tent showering in a waterfall
occasionally being attacked by lemurs uh
and um and
um and needing to you know have having
taken effectively a small pharmacopoeia
of of antibiotics that I might need and
they could you know and things like
antifungals and and topical antibiotics
and such
um but also this this book uh to on a
first aid kit uh to help with things
that that might happen and
um this is a really good book to have
from the um
publisher page
we have this description and you can
show my screen just briefly while I read
this one paragraph here the most widely
used manual for health workers Educators
and others involved in involved in
primary care and health promotion around
the world newly updated in March 2022 to
include the latest information on Burn
treatment Family Planning sexually
transmitted infections epilepsy
treatment vaccination treatment and
preventing malaria and HIV and covet 19.
and one more thing considered by the
World Health Organization to be the most
widely used Healthcare manual in the
world this classic title is for health
workers clinicians Health Educators
midwives Community leaders and others
involved in Primary Health Care delivery
and health promotion around the world
so that's that's the kind of thing this
book is is trying to do and it really is
is an excellent book
um
and throughout it oh one more thing I'll
just read it from my screen throughout
there was an emphasis on addressing the
underlying causes of poor health and a
focus on cleanliness healthy diet
vaccinations and inappropriate cautious
use of medication including an
examination of helpful and harmful home
remedies
so just a little background in this book
okay
chapter 12. prevention how to avoid many
sicknesses oh instantly I found in this
um there's a section on rabies and I
found our original the insert from our
rabies vaccinations
rabies vaccine absorbed uh anyway that's
that's here that's interesting all right
curious to look at that yeah I I have I
have not yet but here we have that um I
will say it's been very effective we
have not not had not gotten rabies not
not once
um okay prevent the top of chapter 12
prevention how to avoid many sicknesses
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound
of cure if we all took more care to eat
well to keep ourselves our homes and our
Villages clean and to be sure their
children are vaccinated we could stop
most sicknesses before they start
in chapter 11 we discussed eating well
in this chapter we talk about
cleanliness and vaccination and they
talk a lot about personal hygiene and
how to build and where to build uh
latrines and how to maintain them and so
that you know so you don't have you know
fecal transfer of disease drinking water
not smoking all of this and then they
also talk about vaccines as I as I said
so they've got
um vaccinations simple sure protection
again this is from 1992.
vaccines give protection against many
dangerous diseases if health workers do
not vaccinate in your village take your
children to the nearest health center to
be vaccinated it is better to take them
for vaccinations while they are healthy
than to take them for treatment when
they are sick or dying vaccinations are
usually given free the most important
vaccines for children are
and they give six
DPT for diphtheria whooping cough that's
pertussis and tetanus
polio
BCG for tuberculosis
measles
not MMR note but measles
tetanus
and smallpox
now two of those are not active
vaccination in the active vaccination
schedule anymore right polio and
smallpox or not and measles the single
measles vaccine has been replaced by MMR
I don't know that tetanus may be in the
third world but um it seems to me that
tetanus is usually recommended only
after exposure at this point I don't
think so I think they give tetanus and
then every 10 years you're supposed to
get another and if you don't know when
you got it and you have had a then you
get an exposed a post-exposure thing
yeah and they don't recommend it for um
until until you're an adolescent for
this one
so there's only six and then they also
have some warnings about vaccine spoil
easily and you know making sure that um
that if you're either the one delivering
it or receiving it that all of the
protocols have been followed
um so this is you know this is a book uh
that is
um Pro vaccine and
um talks explicitly about which ones
admittedly a relatively short list uh
that you should um especially if you are
in the rural developing World should be
sure to be vaccinated against let me
just go back to the beginning here
briefly and share with you the chapter
titles for the table of contents if I
can figure out without knocking over the
zebra and we are the table of contents
is where the hell is it hold on
um it's there's a bunch of front there's
Pages it doesn't matter it's a very
interestingly laid out book but um the
table of contents is not as easy to find
as in some books because there's a lot
of other useful information okay
just the chapter titles through
um chapter nine there are many after
that chapter one home cures and popular
beliefs in which they talk about how I'm
curious and they say that many home
carriers are far better than what you
might get from uh from a pharmacy if you
even have access to a pharmacy but also
talking about some home cures and
beliefs that are likely to cause more
harm than good chapter two sicknesses
that are often confused they talk about
the difference between non-infectious
and infectious diseases they talk I
believe if I remember correctly about
the differences between for instance
bacteria and viruses
chapter 3 how to examine a sick person
they go through all of the major systems
of the body chapter four how to take
care of a sick person chapter five
healing without medicines
with the sections being healing with
water and when water is better than
medicines
chapter six right and wrong use of
modern medicines
chapter 7 antibiotics what they are and
how to use them chapter 8 how to measure
and give medicine and chapter 9 and
there are many chapters after this but
this is where I'm going to stop for the
moment instructions and precautions for
injections
okay so let's let's go there to
instructions and precautions for
injections page 65.
where they say again top of chapter nine
and they've got you probably can't see
it but they've got a syringe right up
close there with a question mark through
it they've got a drawing of a syringe or
the question mark which is their
indication of like should you or
shouldn't you again I read already
the part of the book that says here's
the recommended child vaccine
vaccination schedule as of 1992. when to
inject and when not to
injections are not needed often most
sicknesses that require medical
treatment can be treated as well or
better with medicines taken by math as a
general rule it is more dangerous to
inject medicine than to take it by mouth
injection injection should be used only
when absolutely necessary except in
emergencies that should be given only by
health workers or persons trained in
their use
and then let's just go back a little bit
to chapter six right and wrong uses of
modern medicines
and find
what they have at the top here is a gun
shooting pills okay so they're saying
they've already said
better not to use medicine at all if you
can avoid it water good food rest all of
that is safer than medicine if you have
to have medicine better a pill than a
shot and a shot is your last resource
okay chapter six right and wrong uses of
modern medicines
some medicines sold in pharmacies or
Village stories can be very useful but
many are of no value of the sixty
thousand medicines sold in most
countries the World Health Organization
says that only about 200 are necessary
Remember When The World Health
Organization made sense
back to the book necessary room actin
being on that list yes indeed
also people some I don't know if it was
in 1992 though
it was discovered in the early 80s I
don't know if it was on the whose list
of essential medicines in 1992 or not
back to the reading from the the book
again uh where there is no doctor
also people sometimes use the best
medicines in the wrong way so that they
do more harm than good to be helpful
medicine must be used correctly many
people including most doctors and health
workers prescribe far more medicines
than are needed and by so doing cause
much needless sickness and death are you
listening FDA
there is some danger in the use of any
medicine
some medicines are much more dangerous
than others unfortunately people
sometimes use very dangerous medicines
for mild sicknesses I have seen a baby
die because his mother gave him a
dangerous medicine
chloramphenicol for a cold
never use a dangerous medicine for a
mild illness remember
medicines can kill
this is careful
nuanced reasonable medical advice
aimed at a population
who would not necessarily have access
to what was considered the most
up-to-date and most high-tech medicine
available to those of us in what we then
called the developed world
oh but then called the first world now
we would call it the developed world
supposed to the developing world
that is the sanest thing I have heard
from anything official purporting to
give Health advice at a wide level in
any sort of a mainstream format
since about this time
like where and I you know I think we
will get I'll order the 2022 book and
see if it still makes sense
and I don't know if it will or not but
it cites The Who
favorably
and the who cites this book on the
Publisher's site favorably
as providing
the skills and the information
necessary for people to take their own
health into their own hands
this is what we need
I would love to know
uh I have sense that um
this book would be de facto sacrilege in
a modern medical context because modern
medicine has become so pill happy yeah
um
but I'd be interested to know what what
doctors would think how inconsistent
this is with the training that they
received which does make them overly
aggressive uh with treatments it makes
them uh
underrate the danger of theatrogenic
harm yep
um yeah harm which should probably be
dichotomized there's the atrogenic harm
that comes because somebody did the
right thing for you and
you know you got unlucky and there's the
atrogenic harm that is completely
avoidable that is the result of bad drug
combinations or wrong drug prescribed or
uh you know you put on a ventilator or
when you shouldn't have been I guess
there might be a third category maybe
this isn't considered aetrogenic but uh
you know just just the fact of being in
a hospital puts you at greater risk for
contract for getting something like MRSA
yeah right um and I guess I I feel like
that should be under the rubric of
theatrogenic harm but I'm not sure that
it that it falls there yeah I'm not sure
either but the amount of yetrogenic harm
even if that's excluded is so large yeah
that anyway there's a very different
conversation we should be having and it
should be a conversation that is taken
as Baseline when we get to the question
of you know a one-size-fits-all public
health prescription for
a pandemic for example right what are
the chances that this is going to result
in a massive theatrogenic crisis that we
don't see coming because that's the
nature of them we never had that
discussion no no we don't
um and there's
you know I
those parts of the book that I just
shared were mostly not parts that I've
been familiar with before because
I you know we had been vaccinated
against rabies and yellow fever and a
few other tropical diseases that seemed
important to be vaccinated against given
where you and I are both working
they took with me courses of antibiotics
you know one of which almost certainly
contributed to me rupturing my achilles
tendon you know decades later the the
Cipro the um something phloxamine I
can't remember the class of
ciprofloxacin yeah but know that the
class of drugs
um to which it belongs uh are known now
to uh cause to put uh soft tissue
specifically ligament and tendons at
risk both in the moment while you're on
them and uh long term the more the more
you've been on them uh but yeah I would
I would do some research in advance and
take with me what seemed
um to be most likely to be protective
against the things I was most likely to
run into and be very sparing uh uh in in
taking those things but
you know mostly this book was about
um you know what to do in case of uh you
know extremely urgent problems like
you've broken something yeah uh or you
you know you need to you know someone
someone near you is experiencing
something and you need to figure out
like what things you can do that are
going to maximize them surviving and you
not doing damage to them as you try to
help and so you know having having such
a book in one's in one's personal
library that you're in the field with is
incredibly useful
and yet I feel like now
I'm so grateful to have it in our
library here in the United States right
and I think that most Americans should
have both such such a book and also the
expertise that they glean from reading
such a book
because
increasingly the
the caution about medication represented
in this book is the opposite of what
you're going to get if you actually go
to someone who is paid to help you stay
or get healthy
and that's that seems to be just like
the FDA is doing the opposite of what I
believe it is supposed to be doing
it seems to me that the entire medical
profession and therefore most of the
people who are medical professionals are
doing the opposite of what they're
supposed to be doing
yeah I mean
not but to find a point on it but we're
living in an era where we have
near Universal violations of the
Nuremberg code and the Hippocratic Oath
that's an era in which you need a book
where uh you know
what happens if your doctor is captured
by Pharma
chapter on that this is too early I
guess yeah
um you know there's information on
testing for glaucoma infection of the
tear sac
uh yeah a lot just so
to do with allergic reactions you know
asthma tapeworm
but so good yeah so good and
um
yeah get a copy and maybe uh I'll get
the 2022 version and do a quick perusal
and see how it Compares good and and
come back with that
um
all right anything else I don't think so
all right
well we will
take a bit of a break here and then come
back with a live q a you can ask
questions at darkhorsesmissions.com
and the Q a is only going to be on
Rumble so if you're watching on YouTube
switch over to rumble now I wouldn't
subscribe to the channel it does help us
out and uh and you only have to do it
once on YouTube you subscribe and you
just have to keep redoing it over and
over and over again maybe not everyone
but a lot of people report that to us
hey I got to unsubscribed again well on
Rumble they're not going to do that to
you
subscribe to the channel on Rumble and
uh consider asking a question at
darkhorsesmissions.com we'll be doing
that q a uh shortly and then we'll be
back same time next week we are coming
up starting in July going to start doing
these live streams on a different day
we're going to start doing them on
Wednesdays haven't decided yet on when
but we will give we will start to talk
about that as it as it approaches
and you can uh find us at rumble on
YouTube if you must but a rumble
especially on our patreons uh check out
Brett's new uh subscription thing on
Twitter and
read what I have to say on Natural
Selections and sub stack read our book
and until we see you next time be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside just say no to drug
companies